etonnant non les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire
il était une fois le petit poucet qui
avait 46 ans après qu'il eut
sommairement exécutés le méchant ogre
malgré les vives protestations du mrap
de la licra et de l'association et de
l'association des femmes battues et que
redemande
le petit poucet s'était enrichie en
touchant six fois le tiercé dans l'ordre
lors d'un tournoi et qu'est ce truc est
dans la forêt de chambord hallebardiers
dans la garde royale
deux des frères du vous êtes le petit
poucet avait sept frères c'est vrai que
c'est un chiffre qui porte malheur est
vu dans les navettes comment ça se passe
en europe en hallebardier dans la garde
royale deux des frères du petit poucet
était mort d'un anachronisme à marignan
en 15/100 16 le cadet jean edern poucet
avait succombé à une crise aiguë de
pédomanie bucco-pharyngé lors du fameux
siège de postroff l'aîné bernard-henri
poucet avait explosé en voulant penser
plus haut que son cul le petit poucet et
ses deux frères s'exonère survivants
avaient alors immigré aux amériques où à
force de travail de persévérance
d'escroquerie et chantage diverses
il avait réussi à racheter à la société
johnson and johnson and johnson de
johnson city leurs chaînes de
restaurants du genou pour handicapés
moteurs
hélas les deux frères du petit poucet
était resté espiègle et désobéissant un
jour malgré les conseils de leur petit
frère qui leur recommandaient d'être
bien sage et de ne pas sortir à la nuit
tombée ils sortir à la nuit tombée et
alors dans une taverne mal éclairé il
attrapé le sida en s'asseyant sur un
chef de cabinet malpropre et ils
moururent dans d'atroces souffrances et
ses bienfaits et alors le petit poucet
se retrouva seul à la tête de la
poussette ne poussaient deux poussettes
à johnson city
me voici fort marri dit-il dans sa femme
mais voici fort femme dé tel quel
désarroi ne broient des poux c'est que
vais-je devenir je suis seul mais si
frères sont morts et l'indicé dow jones
est en retrait de deux points par
rapport au précédent exercice
il ne me reste plus qu'à rentrer chez
nous dans l'humble masure forestière où
mes parents les humbles bûcheron ne
manqueront pas de cesse beau dire à mon
humble retour ce qui fut dit fut fait le
petit poucet revendit ses actions et sa
femme un riche armateur levantin et s'en
fut sur un trois mâts au xo hardi les
gars c'est la mer qui prend l'homme
quelle ne fut pas la surprise des vieux
parents à la revoyure de leur enfant
prodigue certes mais pas trop car un sou
est un sou
hélas le temps dans son impitoyable
marche du même nom n'avait pas été
tendre avec les pauvre bûcheron qui
allaient tous les deux vers 80 ans sans
plus jamais quitté les fauteuils d'un
firmes ou la cruelle hémiplégie des sous
bois les clous et mon cher cher enfant
la joie de ton retour me redonne le goût
de vivre dit la mère en mourant d'une
rupture d'anévrisme
c'est un grand malheur qui nous arrive
dit le père changeons nous les idées mon
fils que ne me booste eu dans mon humble
fauteuil d'handicapés moteur jusque dans
la forêt
je ne fut point depuis des lustres eu
égard mon invalidité à 100%
ceux qui refusent redire furent faits
l'un pousse en l'autre le petit poucet
et son papa s'en furent au plus profond
de la forêt après avoir disposé le
fauteuil d'un firme à 100% à l'ombre
d'un grand chêne le petit poucet dit ici
m'ont pas
nous pourrons glander je veux mon neveu
deal vieillard qui était qui était
décidément pas doué pour la tête et les
jambes dans souvient-il mon bon papa du
temps jolie où ma mère et toi essayer de
nous perdre dans cette forêt mes frères
et moi widadi le père qui traduisait
tout en russe en prévision de la
troisième c'était le bon temps mon
garçon mais toi mon bon papa tu n'aurais
pas besoin de semer des petits cailloux
pour retrouver notre humble masure tu
connais le chemin
we have all dit le père parce qu'on sait
jamais
hélas mon garçon je ne saurais mouvoir
tout seul ce fauteuil c'est toi dommage
dit le petit poucet sétois pas de bol
car là tu vois il falloir que je te
quitte wade maire de la twa c'est chacun
son tour lors laissant le pauvre homme
blanc des se sont chaîne il rentre à
tout seul à la maison
chemin faisant il rencontra l'humble
biche mais sans les abois il épousa ils
vécurent heureux
ils n'eurent aucun enfant et voilà
quand quant au mois de mars je le dis
sans est ce vraiment sans aucune arrière
pensée politique
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait étonnant non